Hawaii California Nevada Brazil and
Australia these places have one very
flammable thing in common invasive
grasses these plants are fueling more
frequent and faster burning fires that
are harder to put out and potentially
more catastrophic to human life I'm
going to show you how and what's being
done to fix it grasses are considered
invasive when they take over new
ecosystems where they don't belong cheat
grass which now blankets the basins of
the American West originally came from
either Europe or Eurasia and guinean
buffle grasses which likely played a big
role in the Lahaina fire are from Africa
invasive grasses are among the most
ignitable fuels for fires look at the
grasses it's like a lot of gasoline on
the ground unlike the leaves of trees or
other plants grass doesn't decompose
very quickly it can stick around for a
long time because their leaves are so
thin grasses also dry out fast making
them extra flammable if the air is hot
and dry they will come to zero moisture
content right and if you have a fire
coming down a mountain or a power line
falling into dry grass it's going to
ignite instantly just look back at
places where we've seen intense
grass-fed fires lately or even the
recent fires in Canada Greece and
Washington State dry weather is a huge
contributor and experts say dry seasons
are becoming longer and more extreme due
to climate change under those conditions
grasses can really show how well they
Thrive even in extreme environments
their seeds can Sprout plants very very
quickly you get a little bit of rain
boom they're off they're shallow roots
also expand fast meaning they can grab
water from a large area often way faster
than native plants that puts native
species at a disadvantage add fire to
the mix and that handicap grows because
invasive grasses are very resilient to
fire so after it all Burns all that
comes back is grass that's happening a
lot across the country without taller
trees and shrubs acting like
windbreakers wind speeds go that fans
fires and helps them move faster making
them harder to control in other words
invasive grasses not only fuel fires
they also make the environments they
invade more fire friendly it's called
the grass fire cycle but human activity
is making grass-fueled fires more
problematic and potentially deadly all
of a sudden we're seeing a lot more
fires in places where you wouldn't
expect them like deserts one big issue
was land use for housing and agriculture
more people live in close proximity to
areas that are fire prone in California
there's a lot more people moving into
Wildland areas on December 30th 2021 the
Marshall fire started near Boulder
Colorado it was a fire that started in
dry grass that was completely
surrounding a Housing Development very
similar to the Maui situation that it
didn't have to go very far before it hit
the first house
1084 houses went up in Flames the
Marshall fire got started from burning
trash and a power line that emitted
Sparks in Maui abandoned pineapple and
sugarcane Fields filled up with Guinea
and bubble grasses these invasive
grasses then likely fueled the fire that
destroyed Lahaina another important
variable is emissions all over the U.S
modern vehicles with combustion engines
spread out ammonia which is the nitrogen
source that grasses love it's the
building block of nitrogen-based
commercial fertilizers we're creating a
really nice environment for them to grow
in so does this mean that devastating
fires like the ones in Hawaii and
Colorado are going to become more common
it's a preview of what happens when you
are not prepared and when you are not
planning for the extreme things like
rebuilding roads to make evacuations
easier and retrofitting houses to make
them resilient in a more flammable World
other survival strategies include
controlled Burns of grass invaded areas
and then planting less flammable
vegetation Community preparedness is
also critical we need to imagine our
worst case scenario and then say okay
are we ready